Just about every time that I get involved
in a discussion or a conversation about technological
progress and how it can take away jobs from
people and how it can automate away things
that people used to do, one of the first things
that people talk about this irreplaceable
human skill is creativity, is coming up with
some kind of eureka.
And I think that is simultaneously correct
and not correct at all.
And let me talk first about the way that it's
not correct at all.
There are lots of different definitions of
creativity out there.
One of them that I walk around with is the
ability to come up with a powerful or a useful
legitimately novel idea.
I think that's what creative people, whether
they are innovators or entrepreneurs or investors
or musicians or painters, a lot of what I
think of as creativity is this eureka, this
coming up with something that's valuable or
valued and also pretty novel.
Machines can do that now by any definition
they can do that in lots of different domains.
There's a rapidly growing field called generative
design and what that means is if you feed
into a modern piece of technology the specifications
that you want this building to be able to
handle or this heat exchanger or the frame
of a car or some kind of part out there in
the physical world that has to meet some performance
specifications or fit inside some performance
envelope we've got software that will generate
a part that will do that admirably.
And what's interesting is when you couple
that software to a 3-D printer you print out
these arbitrarily complex shapes that do exactly
what you want them to do.
They're typically very, very high performing,
they're typically very efficient.
They very often look different than what a
human designer would come up with.
When I look at the parts that get churned
out by generative design software they look
skulls or skeletons or exoskeletons that you
see in nature and I was initially surprised
by that.
I don't think I should be surprised by that,
the forms that nature produces are by definition
really, really useful and really efficient
because they've survived all the evolutionary
challenges in history so far and arrived at
this point so they're really beautiful objects.
Generative design software can turn out objects
like that now that remind me a lot of things
that we see in the natural world.
They look different than what human designers
come up with.
They perform better in many cases than what
human designers come up with.
I would call the work of design a very creative
endeavor.
We have technology that's now good at that.
There's also technology that can compose music
in almost any style that you suggest.
And there's an interesting phenomenon going
on there: when people know in advance that
they're going to be listening to computer
generated music they very often dismiss it
as shallow or trivial or obviously not coming
from a human composer's mind and heart.
When listeners don't know in advance that
they're listening to computer generated music
they very often find it as evocative, as beautiful,
as moving as anything a human being would
come up with.
I guess we shouldn't be so surprised by that.
Human taste in music is not this great unknown.
We know some of the rules about what western
listeners, for example, find appealing in
music.
You can bake those rules into software, hit
go and generate a lot of music.
So again, that's an endeavor where I would've
thought of it as creative and computers are
clearly doing at least an adequate job, possibly
a really, really good job.
However, what we haven't seen yet are computers
that can turn out lyrics on top of that music
that sound anything except either really,
really silly or flat out nonsensical and ridiculous.
And if you look at longer form prose that
computers generate, they can generate an arbitrarily
long novel short story set of pros, whatever,
it's gibberish, it's nonsense, it kind of
makes your head hurt in not a good way to
have to plow through this stuff.
And my explanation for why that is is that
computers they just don't know anything about
the human condition.
They're not human.
They haven't evolved in this world.
They don't live with other people in this
world.
They're beautiful mimics of a lot of things,
but when I think about what truly creative
writers and lyricists do is they understand
the human condition, they illuminate it and
they kind of reflect it back to us in a way
that we responded to.
I still haven't seen any piece of technology
do that.
There's a concept from linguistics that I
find it really helpful for understanding computer
creativity and the concept from linguistics
is called the intuition of the native speaker.
And what they mean by that is because I'm
a native speaker of English I can immediately
look at an English sentence and even before
my brain has processed its meaning I know
if it's grammatically correct or not.
I can scan that way before I even know what
I'm doing and I can know if that's a properly
constructed English sentence or not.
I can't do that for any other language and
people who come to English as a later language
can't do it nearly as reliably, nearly as
quickly as I can.
So we native speakers build up this intuition
about the languages that we speak.
The way I apply that to this notion about
digital creativity, we humans have the native
speaker's intuition about the human condition,
about the human world, about the social environment
that we all create.
I'm skeptical, I'm a huge optimist about technology.
Based on what I've seen so far I am really
skeptical that we're going to be able to successfully
convey that intuition, even to a really, really
big really sophisticated piece of technology
or machine learning system.
I just think if that day ever comes it is
a long, long way away.